anaya alexander tendrán que posponer sus
planes por el momento la pareja se
comprometió hace unos pocos meses
ahora la situación en hardcore es más
difícil y no hay esperanza de que se
pueda solucionar
esta mañana él ha venido a dejarla en la
estación fronteriza de chop desde dónde
van a cruzar a hungría junto con una
amiga de su madre
me siento terriblemente pero hay gente
que la está pasando mucho peor rato
[Música]
las despedidas se repiten una y otra vez
en esta estación decenas de padres dicen
adiós a sus hijos y a sus mujeres el
sonó de semana la vida de más de 40
millones de ucranianos ha quedado en el
limbo esto es especialmente impactante
para los niños y jóvenes hoy llenos de
preguntas
irina es una de las cientos de miles de
madres que ha decidido sacar a sus hijas
del país las tres temen por lo que le
pueda pasar al padre que trabaja en el
este de ucrania
esto es inesperado y me siento extraña
no sé no sé me siento mal quería seguir
en el colegio y seguir con la vida
tranquilos
para madres como irina lo más difícil es
como explicar a sus hijas esta guerra
que las ha alejado del mundo en el que
se sienten seguras
no les prohibimos mirar las noticias
hace sangre a dos años ellas ven todo
pero no sé cómo lo procesan
ya en territorio seguro muchas madres
buscando quebrarse tienen que ocultar su
dolor aunque a veces es imposible este
es el caso de natalia que cirujana
hubiera quedado en ucrania para dar
apoyo pero antepuso la seguridad de sus
dos pequeños
ellos lo echan de menos pero el temor es
que no lo veamos más
la gran pregunta que se hacen es cuando
podrán rehacer su vida pero sobre todo
cuando volverán a ver a sus padres
parejas y amigos